es hat sich hingezogen aber jetzt
scheint es endlich zu kommen das lang
und heiß ersehnte bild des schwarzen
lochs im zentrum unserer galaxie gemacht
von event horizon einem riesigen
radioteleskop das durch
zusammenschaltung diverser
radioteleskope rund um die erde
entstanden ist erwartet wird ein absolut
spektakuläres bild das es so bisher noch
nicht gegeben hat und jetzt wurde von
den beteiligten an eventreisen eine
wissenschaftliche sensation angekündigt
das müsste also das bild sein klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
faszinieren die wissenschaft videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen das wird
wirklich sensationell denn bilder die
wir bisher von schwarzen löchern kennen
sind nicht sehr aufschlussreich ist ja
auch verständlich schließlich schlucken
schwarze löcher licht und geben es nicht
ab und jetzt sollen wir zum ersten mal
einen scharfen blick auf das schwarze
loch im zentrum unserer milchstraße
werfen können ein riesiges radioteleskop
soll das ermöglichen im april 2017
machte das event bereisen teleskop eine
spektakuläre aufnahme zahlreicher
radioteleskope rund um die erde wurden
zusammen geschaltet und richteten sich
zehn tage lang auf sagittarius a stern
aus und das ist das schwarze loch im
zentrum der milchstraße und jetzt soll
endlich das bild vorliegen lange haben
wir gewartet denn das das da
fotografiert wurde ist absolut irre
wahrscheinlich gibt es in allen galaxien
so ein super massereiches schwarzes loch
im zentrum absolut gigantisch und
handheld die masse von millionen sonnen
oder sogar milliarden im zentrum unserer
milchstraße
da haben wir ein solches schwarzes loch
gefunden um das zentrum unserer
milchstraße rasen nämlich sterne mit
einem affenzahn der schätze sterben mit
einem tempo von 18 millionen kilometern
pro stunde
alle 15 jahre hat er die runde um seriös
aufstand gemacht so wurde das schwarze
loch in der mitte unserer galaxie
benannt durch diese daten wissen wir
übrigens also aus der entfernung und der
geschwindigkeit ziemlich genau wie groß
auch das schwarze loch ist vier
millionen sonnenmassen und einen schwarz
schild radius von 12 millionen kilometer
das ist der radius des ereignishorizont
ab dessen grenze alles im schwarzen loch
verschwindet materie und licht mit
unserem sonnensystem haben wir
einen sicheren abstand von 26.000
lichtjahren zum zentrum aber ein foto
von diesem schwarzen loch das konnten
wir bisher einfach noch nicht machen es
hat von uns aus gesehen die größe eines
tennisballs auf dem mond und nicht nur
das es so kleines es ist auch so viel im
weg dass es einfach nicht sichtbar ist
das sind nebel aus gas und staub die
einfach die sicht verwehren was also tun
eigentlich ist es einfach aber dann auch
wieder kompliziert elektromagnetische
wellen mit langen wellenlängen
durchdringen diesen nebel aber und jetzt
kommt der haken da sie so langweilig
sind würde ein bild nur sehr unscharf
werden aber die forschungsteams waren
erfinderisch was wäre wenn wir zum einen
ganz viele radioteleskop
zusammenschalten würden
und was wäre wenn wir sie einige tage
auf das schwarze loch richten
ersteres würde das bild deutlich
schärfer machen und durch die dauer der
messung würden wir viel mehr daten
bekommen gesagt getan im april 2017
machte das event horizon teleskop diese
spektakuläre aufnahme zahlreiche
radioteleskope rund um die erde wurden
zusammen geschaltet und richteten sich
eben zehn tage lang auf sacchi carius
aussterben und jetzt soll endlich das
bild vorliegen es wird hammer zumindest
das was wir sehen denn aufgrund der
erdrotation der langen aufnahme wird es
wahrscheinlich wie eine
langzeitbelichtung mit entsprechenden
schlieren und so weiter wie vielleicht
dieses bild aussehen vielleicht können
nur wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler etwas damit anfangen
vielleicht wird es aber auch spektakulär
also auch optisch die letzten daten zur
berechnung sind aus der antarktis vom
dortigen südpol teleskop am 13 dezember
2017 zum haystack observatorien
rechenzentrum in den usa ausgeflogen
worden
eine unmenge an daten deshalb wurden sie
auch bis jetzt berechnet mitbeteiligt an
den berechnungen ist das rechenzentrum
am max planck institut für
radioastronomie in bonn
es wird sehr sehr spannend was wir sehen
werden in diesem gebiet ist die raumzeit
nämlich unglaublich gekrümmt es könnte
also sehr seltsam aussehen aber und das
ist unglaublich spannend wir werden
vielleicht auch hinter das schwarze loch
sehen können es wirkt eher wie eine
gravitationslinse und müsste uns unsere
galaxie hinter ihm zeigen wahnsinn also
am 10 april
da ist es soweit cedric von doktor
watson und ich werden darüber berichten
also auch ihnen abonnieren und hier
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken was
passiert in einem schwarzen loch von
doktor watson bis dann bleibt dran